at the fourth time of asking Parliament
finally approved Boris Johnson's call
for a general election the eyes to the
right 438 the nose to the left 20 so the
eyes of it the eyes have it unlocked an
overwhelming majority of MPs backing a
vote on December the 12th it will be the
first December election in almost a
century the country isn't jus an
election until 2022 but three and a half
years after the brexit referendum
Parliament is stuck and the country no
nearer to leaving the EU we are left
with no choice but to go to the country
to break free from this impasse and to
allow us all to submit as we must in all
humility to the judgement of the
electorate and to allow us to make our
case and above all to allow a new and
revitalized Parliament with a new
mandate to deliver on the will of the
people and get brexit done Boris Johnson
leads a minority Conservative Party
government although he's been able to
get support from the EU for his latest
withdrawal agreement he doesn't have the
same support for that agreement in the
British Parliament he's hoping that by
holding a general election by putting it
back to the people
he'll be able to reconfigure the balance
of power and politics in his favour by
securing changes to the law Johnson was
able to get approval for an election
through a simple majority of MPs rather
than a two-thirds majority as previously
required labour had blocked two possible
election until a No Deal breaks it was
off the table with the EU now offering a
brexit extension until the 31st of
January that condition has been met
we're going to go out there with a very
strong message of how we transform our
society to end inequality and injustice
and deal with the devastating poverty
that so many people face we always said
we wanted an election we do want an
election but we wanted no deal to be
taken off the table we've now had
confirmation from all 28 EU member
states that no deal is off the table
so we're going to go out there with the
biggest campaign this party has ever
mounted
a similar message to from crow II you
parties the Liberal Democrats and
Scottish National Party hoping to
capture the remain vote an election will
be risky for Johnson he promised a
do-or-die brexit on October the 31st and
hasn't delivered some pro brexit voters
may decide to punish Johnson in the
polls by voting for the newly formed
brexit Party and its leader Nigel Farage
the party did very well in recent
European Parliament elections but it's a
risk Johnson and rival politicians are
now prepared to take in the hope of
either delivering or defeating brexit
Nev Barca al Jazeera Westminster